let's talk to the uh foreign secretary
dominic raab who
joins us now look good to see you this
morning is this a definite now do we
need to have a yay or an a by sunday
i think we probably do you never rule
anything out in
talks with the eu the prime minister is
shown he
wants to leave no stone unturned in the
search for a deal that's why he was out
in brussels
uh speaking to ursula van der leyn he's
also
made clear and i think both sides
recognize there are still significant
differences
between them we'll continue with the
negotiations this week i think they'll
take a stop take and decide
the future the negotiations on sunday
and
the the point from the uk side is as i
said we'll leave no stone unturned we
would like a free trade deal with the eu
but we're not going to sacrifice
the basic points of democratic principle
on fisheries on
control over our laws as we leave the
transition period now
i think it's important that that's
recognized
on the eu side and if they do i think
the scope for a deal is still there to
be done
again it's only last year that the prime
minister said that
uh it would be a failure of state craft
if we left with no deal when it comes to
trade i mean
why has it got this far if that's his
view
well we obviously have left with a deal
in terms of the draw agreement and north
valley protocol but in relation to the
fda
frankly we just haven't seen enough
pragmatism and flexibility on the eu
side and it's worth just reminding
um people at home what we're talking
about here we're talking about two
key points there's a range of issues but
two key points
the concept that the uk would leave the
transition period
uh as an independent coastal state but
without control of our fisheries
that's something that no uh country in
the world
would uh that has accepted is in the
position
of why would the uk and likewise
when we leave we should be in control of
our laws we'll accept the
kind of requirements in the eu's own
free trade agreements whether it's korea
um or canada often talked about we're
not going to do is allow the eu
undemocratically to control our laws in
this country and i i think those are
two basic points of principle that no
other country around the world would
um accept in in dealing with the e or
anyone else as an independent state and
i think it's important that the eu um
with it will
recognize that if it does a free trade
deal is still there to be done if it
won't i think on sunday
we take stock and uh we we take a
decision and both sides recognize we
need some finality
on where we are i mean where does that
leave
the uk in terms of negotiation i mean
you know we can make as many demands as
we like it doesn't mean they're going to
be met we've got to be
prepared to compromise on something
haven't we
yes exactly and that's why we got to the
position we have of saying
okay we'll look at the deals that you've
done with canada
um that something like that would seem
to be about right
um and uh we've been flexible on the
issue of fisheries we recognize
uh the need for to transition but what
we're not going to do
is uh indefinitely allow the eu to
control our fisheries or our laws
and i think most people would recognize
that and countries around the world
wouldn't accept those terms
the eu wouldn't accept those terms
dealing with anyone else so
um those are the points of democratic
principle if the eu accepts them
there's a deal to be done but i think uh
given the bridge
the gaps that remain we'll keep going at
it you know that's why the pm was out in
brussels he wants to get a deal
we're doing everything we can i think we
uh uh
behave reasonably and flexibly and
pragmatically throughout
um and if the eu reciprocate that
there's still a deal to be done
if it doesn't we'll take stock we'll do
that on sunday and we'll be prepared to
leave on australia-style terms
and make a success of brexit but there
is going to be some fallout as
i mean as we look at that being
certainly a very
realistic possibility at this stage i
mean there are reports in the papers
this morning that come the first of
january
people from the uk may not be able to
just
travel in europe as freely as they they
have done partly because of the covid
restrictions what have you but no
exemptions for the uk and this could
have
sort of very strong impacts on the
british people very quickly couldn't it
well if it's right to say i mean in any
event there'll be changes come january
with a free trade deal or even if we
leave on australia style terms that's
certainly true
um there'll be uh some froth around
those changes but i think we're well
placed with the
contingency planning that we're doing to
brace those and make a success of brexit
um you mentioned travelling the eu of
course the eu is already we've already
agreed
that uh in any case that there will be
um uh the uk travelers can
can go on visa waiver to the eu for uh i
believe it's 90 out of 100
days at a time so in terms of the usual
course of
uh travel um there's already
arrangements that will deal with that
but you're right to say that it it may
be bumpy if we don't get a free trade
deal
on the other hand there are positive
signs this trust has amassed a whole
range of free trade deals
not just with existing eu partners um or
indeed other partners that have
done deals with the eu but there for
example the japanese
uh free trade deal goes beyond the eu
president with data
and digital um we know that from merck
the pharmaceutical company to netflix
uh just recently in the matter of last
few weeks that both of those
have announced plans for new hubs in
london because they see from pharma to
creative uh industries the uk is a world
leader
so i i do think there will be some
changes i do think it could be bumpy in
certain areas but also huge
opportunities
i don't think we should lose sight of
that we're going the extra mile we're
leaving no stone unturned
to try and get an fta with the eu but
they've got to be reasonable about those
points of principle as i said look i'm
sure just about everyone uh
watching this at home have seen the
adverts
that the government's put out for for
businesses small and large alike saying
you know changes are coming you need to
be prepared for the changes
i mean the problem for business would
seem to be they don't know what those
changes
are how can anyone prepare for something
that's going to happen in three weeks
and we don't know what it is
well that's not quite right there some
of the um changes will come
on either eventuality um and what we've
been doing is communicating
uh all the likely requirements and what
the difference between
having an fda and leaving on australian
style terms would be but you're right to
say and i certainly said
we need some point of finality to give
them certainty so that they can
know which set of rules and which set of
um
uh uh approaches and declarations that
they need to
to adhere to that's why sunday i think
is an important moment
you never say never in these talks but i
think we do need to get some finality
for the reasons that you've given
um i think we'll get that on sunday i
think both sides recognize it's time for
that
just a final thought on this uh you
think i mean it
is sunday a hard deadline or not
i think we view it as a point uh where
we need some finality
i'm just a bit reticent uh ever to say
you know you can never say never with
these eu negotiations and of course it
depends
uh if the eu moves if the eu moves
substantially
and actually we're only dotting a few
eyes or crossing a few t's
might be different but i think without
movement on the crucial two
three areas that i've described um i
think that that will be a point of
finality
um and that's certainly the way that the
uk side is approaching it
um can we move on to the vaccine uh if
we can because i mean what a week it's
been i mean
absolute absolutely momentous and very
emotional
for a lot of people including the health
secretary so we understand seeing these
vaccines
being rolled out but the health
secretary did make the point that
once the most vulnerable were vaccinated
life can begin to go back to normal well
the editor-in-chief of the lancet
richard horton
has said that is absolutely not the case
what is the reality here
so the reality is uh it's uh it's great
news that we've started rolling out and
getting these vaccines
uh in the arms of people uh and we're
starting off with those over 80
healthcare workers we then transition to
those uh who
who who are over um 60 uh
social care workers residents in care
homes and we've basically got a road map
until
we expect to be the the spring where the
those over um 50 those uh who've got
uh vulnerable health conditions and the
key workers that i mentioned
have had the requisite vaccinations you
need to have two
and at that point we can transition back
to something akin to normal
but it is a mouth and not a sprint and
we're not there yet
and so um we're well placed with this
vaccine we're the first ones to get this
uh get this rolling out that's good news
uh but equally there's some way to go
and it's really important that between
now and the spring
we don't take our eye off the board in
terms of the tiered restrictions
that each area will have because the
virus is still very much with us and
we need to maintain control over it as
foreign secretary you you've got to be
keeping an eye on this one
and it look admittedly it is hugely
difficult we've brought up
um you know tens of millions of doses of
vaccine and pre-ordered
left right and center as have an awful
lot of countries
the people's vaccine alliance says
nearly 70 lower income countries will
only be able to vaccinate
one in 10. how do how do we balance that
out i mean how do we look after the uk
look after our citizens while also
standing up to our responsibility
to the international community in third
world countries
yeah he's a great question look first of
all we've got
355 million doses secured
and we've got seven different suppliers
coming down the track
subject to the regulatory approval so
we've got quite a diverse supply chain
because i know
that's something people have been asked
because of course our first duty our
first priority is to make sure
the british people are as safe and
protected as possible but you're
absolutely right that we're only as safe
as the weakest link in this global chain
it's a global
pandemic and we need global solutions
and we feel a great sense of duty and
moral responsibility but also
british interest in making sure uh
poorer people around the world
vulnerable countries get the vaccine
that's why this prime minister
led the gabi vaccine summit and raised
smashed the target raising 8.8 billion
dollars
for that equitable international
distribution that's why we've been a
leader on kovacs
which is the mechanism to allow poorer
countries access to that
vaccine we're a world leader in this um
and
so yes whether whether it's the the
research that we're seeing at oxford and
imperial
whether it's getting uh the roll out of
the vaccines which we've managed to do
this
this uh this week uh right the way
through to the international
leadership that we're providing we're
making sure that we
are not just looking at our secretary
the british people but also
the rest of the world very good to talk
to you this morning